c'est une séquence diffusée sur les
réseaux qui depuis quelques jours choc
de nombreux internautes mais aussi les
forces de police dont ces images sont
tombés entre les mains
les images sur lesquelles alix des
moineaux candidate star de l'émission
les marseillais sur w9 insulte
copieusement des policiers en train de
réaliser un contrôle de routine selon la
jeune femme ces contrôles seraient
toujours réalisés sur la même population
tout en se filmant la jeune femme passe
devant ces policiers en les insultant
des images qui ont beaucoup choqué
certains internautes mais aussi le
secrétaire général d'unité sgp fo un
syndicat de police qui a décidé d'écrire
un courrier à ce sujet au ministre de
l'intérieur je ne peux pas accepter la
diffusion de tels propos sur les réseaux
sociaux ce sont avant tout des propos
délictueux à l'encontre de notre
institution et de celles et ceux qui la
représentent
il a également demandé à ce que ces
actes soient punis en demandant à
christophe castaner de tout mettre en
oeuvre pour rechercher et interpeller
les auteurs de ces publications
absolument intolérable alors alix des
marseillais insulte la police doit-elle
être condamné alors qu'est ce que vous
en pensez
ils n'ont rien valérie boffrand
honnêtement je note est condamné on
demande aux téléspectateurs allaient
dans quelques minutes on aura également
à prendre ou à laisser et on va avant le
quart d'heure son fils condamné je ne
sais pas mais qu'elle se taise enfin
elle ne sait pas elle ne fait pas ce
qu'il a de la scène de voir ce qui s'est
passé avant ce qui se passe pendant elle
la ramène pas ce qu'elle a envie de la
ramener pour essayer de se faire mousser
sur les réseaux tétouan ma fille tu es
toi fait on me fit alors ça c'est une
belle femme et oui et quand il y en a
presque gênant c'est que c'est des
exemples où beaucoup de jeunes de les
admirer sa balle on pleure pas donc leur
parole est important donc faut pas dire
n'importe quoi qu'on ait un but une
écoute et d'art plus parler seront
caméra comme ça qu'on passe sans
s'arrêter à la semoy qu'elle s'arrête
que le leur dise les choses en face par
en passant comme ça sur lala sera pas
j'suis désolé
oui ma mamie exactement comme van persie
alors jouer merci oui vraiment j'aime
bien le terme dérapages thunder a pas
assez motivé c'est tout à fait ça la
barrière dire est-ce qu'elle puisse
accuser aller dans une voiture elle
insulte des gens elle n'est pas comme tu
as dit s'il avait été en phase là tu
dois c'est un outrage
là on parle pas doute rage mais j'aime
bien le mot dérapages parce que mon
attention les filles attention les gars
ont fait pas des trucs comme ça parce
que ça peut vous amener à regarder
castaner est terminée dans ma peau vous
emmenons tall ça peut voir et puis là je
veux dire barrette à la fin c'est
l'escale un dérapage en dérapage en
dérapage qui aime bien le mot dérapages
merci
merci moi c'est un outrage excusez-moi
effectué voile insulté publiquement la
peña san vial via son téléphone c'est un
dérapage inter c'est un dérapage c'est
vrai que ça nous rend votre au tréfonds
de notre bassesse humaine mais ça reste
ça reste pour moi un dérapage et un
autre âge